in these older leagues or if they--if
golden boy if that's your thing to do
like these this Master League everyone
fighting that League better pray to the
MMA gods Vitor Belfort does not enter
that [ __ ] theme juice to the gills oh
yes you better just amazing fantastic
that [ __ ] out of all those old dudes at
the same time dude I was gonna Instagram
the other day I was like oh my god yeah
there's something happens to Vitor when
he fills up with super unleaded dude
it's like peanut butter and jelly he's a
different his words bro like some people
don't don't don't do well with Roy to
get all bread and [ __ ] he looks great
his skins vibrant his tits are popping
he's all tan his teeth get wider he's
doing straight testosterone he's not
mean when he was on si think about this
right we know for sure we all know
absolutely 100% the people have cheated
and taken steroids and got away with it
we know that I know us we know that
especially in fighting especially when
the the weigh-ins were the only day you
had a pee yeah there was no random they
didn't just come by we know for a fact
but when you watch someone who's just
doing testosterone and what else he's
doing with a human growth hormone and
[ __ ] gigantic now I love that V love
it too but what you get there it's a
different thing like for Vitor like
something happens with him like when you
when they allowed him to take it like
during the rock hold file and this big
fight dude his body ate it up but that's
a it's a kind of a different thing
because you're it's like it's above
board right let me let him do it so he
doesn't feel guilty about it you feel me
he still he's finding a way where it's
still legal yeah when he was doing it
yeah he was doing it legally he was
doing it legally he got permission from
the UFC to do it yeah the Commission so
what you want to say if you go back
before he did it like would you see when
he fought sexy ama
yes dude his body didn't look nothing
like that it looks like a welterweight
right and everyone wants to go the of
people go oh he did steroids with
whatever sport Sammy Sosa mark mcgwire
Barry Bonds you take steroids try
hitting those [ __ ] homeruns everyone
was doing it in fighting a lot of people
were doing I'm looking same
if so when John Jones tested hot against
DC right for whatever he does hot for if
DC was doing the same stuff would he
have beat John the answer is no what was
a very close fight up into that head
kick right it was a good fight you don't
you really never know what could have
happened I'm just saying let's say high
level fighting correct however but
however that's what happens we have to
judge it based on that if they are
taking the same stuff whatever you want
to say John took but if DC is saying do
you think the outcome would've been any
different my answer is no if they were
taking the same see the the John thing
we've gone over this but we probably
should go over this again if anybody
doesn't know the actual the numbers he
tested negative then he tested positive
for a miniscule amount was really small
and then he tested negative again so
whatever happened happened in a very
short window and it was an incredibly
small amount of whatever that stuff was
some call it micro dosing yeah it could
be that maybe you know we don't know
really yeah the the thing about it is
that stuff is supposed to stay in your
system for a long time it would be a
stupid thing to take because supposedly
it's in your system for weeks
mm-hmm but we don't know yeah and also
the micro dosing [ __ ] is real folks
that's real I mean that's what they were
doing in baseball they were taking
testosterone gummy bears and they would
only last like three or four hours and
they said hey rival eyes did era I would
eat them during the game yeah yeah and
then by the time the game was over its
out of system yeah and baseball would
that was testing baseball players just
Adamas [ __ ] but it was one of those
weird American things like everybody's
[ __ ] or treatin but if we had the
Russians attitude about this just be
cool man if I mean what is it like like
how do the Russians feel about like that
documentary Icarus where that guy came
on claim that all the Russian athletes
run steroids they don't address like ya
know [ __ ] buddy anyways whatever let it
whatever we're just gonna get over it
man kill a few whistleblowers over here
don't - yeah come over here let me know
it works out for you ya know but wonder
put that stuff with steroids I think we
put too much we almost put too much
emphasis on the steroids wait don't get
wrong it [ __ ] helps in
a lot of guys but if if everyone was on
the same thing John Jones would still be
the greatest all-time he's still
undefeated Rock Brock Lesnar and still
be Brock Lesnar I think Kane would still
be Kane still be it I think everything
would be the exact same I got I got to
be serious here man I think you're right
if everybody was on the results would be
the same if everybody was on the problem
is like some people like Vitor just it
just his body loves it he's made for ya
his body's made for TRT replacement